nowadays you literally described it  earlier right that the beauty standard  now  right is curvaceous woman that didn't  used to be the standard at all the  standard used to be  slim  straight down right and a big reason why  it's changed is because in hip-hop  culture has become mainstream so  anything that's that's admired about  hip-hop has now become part of the  mainstream standard right right  so now all the quote-unquote high-value  men  are picking these type of women like kim  k so now every girl wants to have boobs  every girl wants to have a bomb  every girl has to have a tiny waist  right like my man over there was saying  like  yes models are still a thing  but actually for the commercial  especially for the new generation for  most that's not the beauty standard that  most people of our generation are  choosing now well that's we're not  talking